é bom quando me convidaram pra falar
sobre curiosidade eu achei curioso
porque eu não entendi se eu sou um cara
curioso ou se me acho um cara curioso e
aí eu comecei a perguntar o que é a
curiosidade por algumas pessoas para mim
consegui entender o que é a curiosidade
de verdade e cada um falar alguma coisa
então não consegui entender de verdade
que a curiosidade
isso de certa forma me deixou um pouco
curioso então fui procurar a qual que é
a curiosidade e quando eu fui para o
paredão não impediu que a curiosidade
curiosidade é um instinto humano
bom então sou um cara curioso é um
instinto
só que eu achei que a equipe já está
falando muito pouca coisa sobre
curiosidade
já procurei me pedir em inglês para ver
e falar um pouco mais sobre curiosidade
porque devem ter muito mais estudos
sobre curiosidade e quando chega no
clube inglês o que podia falar que
curiosidade não é um instinto humano
aconteceu isso é que é o tipo da func
ela é um instinto humano ou ela não é um
instinto humano
e aí eu fiquei eu acho mais curioso
então eu sou meu background de
tecnologias o programador originalmente
depois trabalhei com arte trabalha com
ar de trabalho com um monte de outras
coisas
não sei se é porque eu gosto só porque
eu sou um cara curioso mas que eu fiz eu
fui cantá-la estruturar o porque o cara
me convidou para falar sobre curiosidade
então vou tentar me entendem primeiro
então a primeira coisa que eu fizer vou
tentar nadar com veia de genética
curiosidade aqui então eu tento entender
uma genética o que eu vi que o trouxe da
minha mãe que me mostrou também ou as
coisas que eu uso hoje que me
influenciaram de alguma forma
então em casa minha mãe é gamer gamer
hardcore não entende bastante tecnologia
e fez bastante eletrônica
e programação também comecei ela me
ensinou programado
então ela me trouxe programação meu pai
é um empreendedor nato e ele é um
trabalhador e eu nunca tive essa
separação do que o trabalho do que a
vida pessoal ele sempre gostou ele ama
que ele faça isso é muito natural para
mim isso foi muito interessante também é
bem parte da minha personalidade também
à minha família ea família gigante eles
fazem festas todo final de semana então
grupo muito grande de gente eles acordem
todo mundo chega perto também
eles gostam disso é uma coisa que de
certa forma parece um pouco do que eu
venho fazendo também a minha cidade é
verdade uma cidade que fala que tem
muito sobre a arte é uma cidade muito
interessante disse
uma cidade que tinha que teve as
melhores faculdades de tecnologia no
passado também então essa combinação na
tipo de arte de design e tecnologia
acho que ajudaram a formar um pouco
talvez da minha curiosidade
só que eu não não bastava eu comecei
como eu preciso analisar tudo que certa
forma essas variáveis começar a
influenciar na vida então eu fiz um
outro gráfico para tentar analisar tudo
que eu tô fazendo nos últimos anos o que
lembrava que estava fazendo e aí desci
gráfico uma coisa começa a perceber se
vai passando mas esse tipo de gente que
percebe o cinza desse gráfico é o que
ele chega mas agora eu estou fazendo
mais coisas estão tocando talvez mais
curioso porque não necessariamente era
aquilo que eu deveria estar fazendo se
focar em alguma coisa mas eu não gosto
de colocar alguma coisa então talvez
seja por isso que esse cara me convidou
falar sobre a curiosidade porque não
gosta de falar alguma coisa de algumas
coisas na então comecei a tocar
tecnologia depois outro com design e
comecei a aprender a empreender diversas
outras empresas e dentro dessas coisas
dentro dessas dessas coisas que hoje eu
e certa forma estudo tem itens aqui como
racks de indústria robótica inteligência
artificial é educação realidade virtual
a arte mesmo que estou mais envolvido a
expansão de consciência então tem várias
coisas que eu tô tentando
transformar em projetos pra mim vou ver
que eu não sei se isso é trabalho está
pessoal mas não me interessa
então eu vou começar a mostrar pra vocês
algumas coisas que eu tô fazendo depois
pra vocês me ajudarem respondesse c
eu sou uma pessoa curiosa não sou um
cara curioso uma das coisas que eu tô
fazendo então isso é uma coisa de
robótica na então a gente sabe vocês
devem a que não se falou aqui mas o
fenômeno das impressoras 3d também uma
das coisas que eu fiz logo que isso
começou eu comprei uma impressora 3d ea
gente montou essa impressora e é o que
eu vou fazer eu fui escanear o meu
crânio e tentar imprimir o meu crânio em
3d e ele está aqui
esse aqui é o meu crânio impressa em 3d
hoje só que não existe não eu procurei
não existe uma pessoa que eles ganhou
grande imprimiu grande 3 10 o que
imagina a gente já fala disso de
aplicações para a medicina na verdade né
a saúde porque é uma coisa contou grande
tem um modelo deu crédito pode reportar
o crânio não sei mas talvez uma parte
dele consiga mas tem outras aplicações
também imagina os fãs da lady gaga com o
brinquinho que é o crânio dela também
ou os fãs do quadrado com tênis que
aperta o botão na ucrânia do cabo branco
eo tênis enche também então tem outras
aplicações
mas isso não sei exatamente porque eu
vou usar mas a gente conseguiu fazer
mais isso abriu a cabeça para muitas
outras coisas que a gente está fazendo
hoje profissionalmente eu dei essa
matéria na diretiva sobre um cara que
deve fazer uns dois três anos mas sou um
cara que ele sofreu um acidente em um
acidente na verdade são soldado
americano no afeganistão
a bomba química e esse cara queimou por
dentro
e esse cara ele sente uma dor que não
consegue curar e aí comecei a estudar um
pouco mais nessa matéria falava um pouco
disso que a única forma de curar a dor
desse cara da realidade virtual à
realidade virtual mais forte que a
morfina então conseguiam controlar um
pouco a dor desse cara com alucinógenos
conseguiram travar parador desse cara
com realidade virtual
nossa pra mim foi chocante também é uma
coisa que eu sempre me interessei e
agora está acontecendo de verdade porque
tem equipamento possível de realidade
virtual que a gente consegue transferir
a mente das pessoas do próprio lugar
somente do cara pra outro lugar ele não
sente mais nesse corpo que o corpo
físico e olha como isso é interessante
ainda é realidade virtual e eu quando
era pequeno eu tirava fotos dos jogos
que eu jogava porque participar de
campeonatos e tal mas a partir de agora
terá uma foto física do negócio virtual
comecei a pesquisar sobre isso encontrei
caras que fazem fotos de mundos virtuais
e é ver se isso vai acontecer as pessoas
vão fotografar elas não vivem os
virtuais muita gente vai escolher sair
desse mundo para aquele outro mundo
porque nesse mundo vive no corpo de dor
só que naquele outro mundo também existe
beleza e algumas pessoas já estão
registrando e essa foto pra esse cara
tirar essa foto com essa luz desse lugar
esse cara tem que ficar duas horas pela
montanha para chegar o momento exato que
algo estava ali para tirar uma foto mas
isso é um ambiente virtual no ambiente
real está ela tem uma exposição inteira
desse cara que o leonardo sangue que um
brasileiro
lá na empresa que trabalho e eu também
vou desenvolver alguns projectos de arte
junto com a esposa que usa essas coisas
que são esses novos óculos de realidade
virtual que isso ainda não se vende para
o consumidor final mas para
desenvolvedores já se vende a gente
conseguiu comprar alguns protestar mas
porque já está testando está virando um
negócio também só que como nunca se a
parede do pessoal da profissional eu não
estou fazendo isso por causa minha se
inscreveram negócio de verdade tanto faz
também manchete em neurociência
eu sou um cara de exatas trabalho da
semana publicidade também não tem
algumas empresas têm algumas agências
estão na publicidade e na publicidade
para alcançar consumidores a pagar
dinheiro para investir em mídia e bom
como todo mundo consegue falar com todo
mundo conseguir eu consegui não está num
projeto de de pra terminar o ebay mas eu
escrevi uma forma uma marca nunca mais
gastar dinheiro e mídia paga só que a
única variável que influenciam essa
fórmula é uma variável que depende do
valor da mensagem está entregando para
eu conseguir perceber o valor da
mensagem
eu criei um outro algoritmo que analisa
as emoções das pessoas
entender que nível de emoção pela
consentindo pra ver como essa variável
influencia essa fórmula de fazer a
pessoa gasta mais dinheiro e menos
dinheiro no final quando estava dizendo
esse algoritmo uma coisa percebia
situacional uma pessoa ou deixá la feliz
foi a mensagem verdadeira e simples tem
o melhor resultado possível
então é um causo bem pra alguém gastar
menos dinheiro então por causa da
engenharia e da matemática que a gente
tem se a gente está estimando marcas a
fazer o bem para outras pessoas no final
elas gastaram menos dinheiro
isso até que mais me estimula dentro da
felicidade e muita muita gente vê uma
coisa que não é tão legal e eu também
não acho legal mas poder desposar
influenciar as pessoas a fazer o bem
para os outros disso vai a gente sabe
que vai batendo bolso do cara você fizer
o bem ele vai gastar menos grand ele vai
começar a fazer o bem para os outros
também já está conseguindo influenciar e
usar essas formas esse e esse pensamento
pra influenciam marcas a fazerem o bem
pra gente testar o algoritmo gente usa
esse outro brinquedinho aqui o cara bota
na cabeça a gente consegue saber o nível
que ele está no algoritmo depois de se
estimular com a mensagem
então eu sei com isso aqui eu vejo que o
cara sente influência direta o quanto de
grana
o cara tem que gastar ativismo eu sou
muito
eu gosto muito disso na verdade eu sinto
que esse é um dos possíveis caminhos de
algum futuro próximo vai mas foi um
outro projeto que a gente usou fazendo a
fórmula que a conheci dois caras que
tinha uma idéia incrível
e essa idéia encaixa exatamente na forma
de deixar as pessoas felizes e emocional
das pessoas era verdadeiro e era simples
e aí quando escutei essa idéia eu falei
eu quero fazer eu te ajudo a fazer e aí
trouxe para dentro de casa eu e meu time
a gente ajudou essa idéia com sam e essa
idéia nada mais era que ela resolveu o
problema não fixa uma reflexão da
sociedade
não é que a gente tem uma cidade com a
cidade da sociedade numa cidade que são
paulo é uma cidade cinza
nessa cidade cinza existe um movimento
muito forte envolvimento de gru
a fitch as pessoas querem colorir a
cidade só que o governo acaba não
deixando que isso acontece esses caras
são considerados criminosos muitas vezes
a sociedade é uma cidade colorida os
caras querem pintar o governo não quer
só que se quem tem as cidades com as
pessoas porque se eles não podem da
cidade
esses caras querem pintar pode criar uma
plataforma que faz o cara que tem um
muro do muro para a plataforma e o cara
que a pintar vai lá pega um muro pintado
à dorê pinta porque se murta doado
ele é um criminoso mais linda maria
braga se explica melhor que a gente o
crédito na verdade vamos dizer assim
como outras usuais deve ser um fim do
mundo fez cinzas em cor né
do outro lado tem os grafiteiros né e
vocês não se conhecem esses grafiteiros
estão loucos pra um espaço pra ir lá e
mostrar a arte deles mostrar a expressão
mais bonita né que eles têm através das
cores da astin aí surgiu um site na
internet que junta eu diria assim a fome
com a vontade de comer como a china que
em um ano bom só que isso agora tem tem
milhares de mudas doadas no mundo
inteiro é uma coisa só de são paulo até
lá em pelotas o que ajudou muito o cara
pintor ninguém controla não tem ninguém
cuidando desse site é só uma plataforma
foi criada uma tecnologia agora todo
mundo chega lá e pode doar um muro e
outro pode clicar no botão e pintar e
acabou só que está no mundo inteiro o
google entrou como parceiro neste
projeto no brasil e agora lançando mais
outros três ou quatro países
oficialmente mas já em diversos países
do mundo também disseram pra gente uma
reflexão na sociedade que tem um
filminho explica ele
rapidinho melhor também
a revolution storz única equipe do
portal foi dias indica já vânia tem um
entendimento quanto ao futuro é isso
square max pipo rap
um senhora em clientes e espera por isso
isto é o ineti skies técnica telefone é
não desligamos morre na hora
buenos aires domingo aos dealers ae
espina
não vou levá los angeles cheguei em
jonas
é meio que o cheirinho da cal cheirinho
bom essa outra coisa eu tenho criou
muito e gosta de criar rápido inventar
idéias muito rápido e eu queria um
processo para inventar idéias muito
rápido aqui trabalha com criação de
sinapses e e trazer memórias antigas e
misture com memórias novas e tal mas tem
um outro aparelho que eu tô começando os
ataques vão mostrar pra vocês
quando eu coloco isso estimula seu
córtex frontal com esse estímulo
elétrico ele faz com que as sinapses
criadas seja mais forte porque
obviamente acordo entre cidade no
cérebro também então isso são coisas
tecnologias que estão chegando aqui no
final a gente traz para o nosso dia a
dia que a gente não sabe exatamente qual
é o resultado ainda mas são coisas novas
eu gosto de testar suas brincadeiras
também isso no final acaba e porque não
a gente fala que a tecnologia é uma
coisa natural mas na verdade tecnologia
foi inventado pela gente uma pedra
tecnologia então pra mim não faz
diferença se está dentro para fora do
meu corpo
o celular que a gente fala que a
tecnologia disse kacey em casa dói a
barriga da barriga então ainda parte do
corpo também então é tudo uma coisa só
né
isso é a última coisa só pra mostrar pra
vocês né evolução exponencial isso é uma
coisa que eu vejo dando muito também na
então o que o que que o que nessa
análise
chegou um ponto e chegou num ponto de
inflexão que a evolução está muito
rápido ea tecnologia acelera o processo
e tecnologia acelera vários processos
mas hoje a gente tem um poder de
processamento de um inseto amanhã vai
ser de um rato depois você de um ano
depois vocês todos humanos juntos a
gente não tem como dar contra isso nunca
vai ter uma sociedade que vai ter menos
tecnologia e que vai ter uma sociedade
que vai ter menos muda - mudança vai
mudar mais devagar
isso traz outras coisas também que a
gente vai ter uma sociedade crescer
menos transparente por cima cidade vai
ser menos verdadeira enchente é uma
consciência está conectada
uma das coisas que a sociedade traz
também é uma fragmentação fragmentação
muito grande isso é interessante que a
distribuição muito maior e hoje eu tô
com uma holding que hoje elas são 14 são
três empresas na verdade
deve fechar algumas outras empresas até
o final do ano mas isso aqui é mais ou
menos meu dia a dia isso é o que eu tô
gerindo cada bandeirinha dessas é uma
empresa diferente mas o que é mais
importante é que a lógica que a gente
quer aplicar a partir do aprendizado que
eu tenho te desse tipo de estudo é que
essas empresas nunca mais vão ser
grandes impérios ao invés das minhas
empresas elas crescerem elas vão
diminuir
elas vão se fragmenta eu vou
compartilhar o valor delas com mais
pessoas início vou conseguir criar uma
sociedade que ela pode ser mais
sustentável
mas tomara que ao mesmo tempo mais
divertida mas é um pouco disso que eu tô
fazendo também isso é também um pouco de
uma análise que vai em cima de algumas
projeções matemáticas mas um pouco de
percepção e sensibilidade está
acontecendo no mundo que na volta então
do que não se fique pensando que quem eu
sou de onde é que vem a curiosidade e aí
eu escutei algumas coisas hoje minha
esposa também falou uma coisa que é
interessante né
ela me falou que curiosidade de mantém
jovem né
alguém falou aqui também que curiosidade
é vida
esse curiosidade é a busca por uma
resposta
eu não quero encontrar porta resposta
porque graças a deus não tenho a mínima
ideia da onde que teve a curiosidade